stop before this video begins let me
tell you by great sponsor nordvpn you're
browsing the internet unprotected
i can see what you're doing you know
that right i can see everything it's
okay i'm not judging
because with nordvpn there's a strict no
logs policy for those who don't know
another vpn helps you browse internet
securely safely and freely if you're not
using a vpn your isp internet service
provider can see exactly what you're
doing online sorry to say incognito mode
doesn't actually incognito move you know
i mean if you're browsing on a public
wi-fi it's very easy for people to snip
up your passwords and personal
information nor vpn covers you from that
and what i really like norvpn for it's
not just feelings is safe and secure but
also it bypasses any region block you
can connect all across the world with
simple click of a button it only takes a
few seconds and bam i'm in japan baby i
can watch anime now it only costs a few
bucks a month and if you use the link in
description you get an even better
discount so make sure you use it it's
nordvpn.com pewdiepie if you use the
offer you get a huge discount and an
additional four month for free so sign
up i highly recommend it take control of
your internet experience today with
nordvpn that's nordvpn.com
pewdiepie you're welcome also it's
literally risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee try it out if it's
not for you money back baby now let's
get into the video ken
felix if you had a million dollars what
would you buy
what would i buy god dang i would buy
some real estate and invest it because
i'm an adult nothing because you live in
australia and you can't afford it
that's true that's true it doesn't give
me anything what does a million dollar
buy around the world well speaking of
that i can tell you exactly what it gets
you in australia uh in sydney where i am
right now you get like a shack down by
the under the bridge with the homeless
people
you're a millionaire congratulations oh
wait you're in australia never mind
so it's sad
it's the same with you cam i want to
show you what you can buy but i'm sure
they're going to show us too i'm really
curious about this very own million
dollar check the only condition is that
you can only use it to buy a house you
can choose oh okay fair enough yeah
that's what i want to know anyway yeah
live anywhere in the world europe asia
australia the americas even a private
the americas are you plural now
yeah there's multiple the united states
you know of america oh right that's many
yes of course sorry island in the
caribbean you can finally settle down in
the environment you've always dreamed of
be that a modern see this is also
another lie that i was fed all right i'm
like oh cool i can work from anywhere i
have
i have income
where do i want to live yeah that's
right japan wait never mind you okay
hey you can it's a lie
you can't just go anywhere
it's been two years you gotta have
internet too so yeah you have my
experience it's more expensive
yeah
this video pisses me off rich people
problem
yeah i'm pissed off waterfront views or
a penthouse apartment in a new york or
dubai skyscraper as you'll quickly
discover a million dollars can go a
mighty long way or in some particularly
affluent areas
come on come on get into it need some
help deciding where to move let's take a
look at what seven figures will buy us
across every corner of the globe that's
another thing that pisses me off when
people say seven figures just say a
million
yeah i had to math out i was like seven
figures that's like seven hundred
thousand dollars
kicking off our journey around the world
is the city that never sleeps a place
home to over 8 million people the
bustling metropolis that is new york
city why would anyone ever live in that
hell hole i will never understand first
time i came to new york there was
garbage on the streets i never heard so
much noise homeless people everywhere it
just seems like wait people want to live
here
oh okay no you mean not the homeless
people all the millionaires that can't
afford to live here yeah yeah yeah
those guys because it's going to be so
expensive they're going to be like seven
hundred thousand dollars you get you in
new york and it's like a bedroom yeah
and like a mat oh it's a first night
even a bed yeah that's insane also for
the record and with the homeless people
i mean like the dystopian uh atmosphere
oh
i don't know everyone interprets
everything i say in different ways
but on its infamous central island the
skyscraper-tastic borough of manhattan
the prices get even higher and the
apartments get even smaller the median
price for a one-bedroom apartment here
is almost a million bucks so that the
medium is a million
damn
nice that's exactly what we can expect
to buy but you have quick access to like
a starbucks so that's cool right you
just got you just gotta wait for the
elevator to go down 50 floors and then
you're right there it's amazing on the
subway and go to work you know it's
great
[Music]
you just gotta crime yourself in with
all the other people that don't want to
be there it's awesome you can choose
from a one-bedroom 640 square foot
apartment in the west village that comes
with a private terrace and gym in the
building or go for this one another
one-bedroom straddling murray hill in
midtown it's a two-story open
wow that looks wonderful exposed brick
wall you know that's lovely isn't it oh
man that's so
so rustic so rustic aka it's also cheap
because they have to play thing over it
look at this
kitchen that can cram into a closet
basically
five cabinets nice nice this is above it
you know you can cool down your heat so
that you have to put in the microwave
your totino's pizza you don't even have
space for a microwave in this kitchen i
like the microwave yeah oh they added
more space outside the kitchen so that
yeah it's so smart it's so smart
story open floor plan on the top open
floor plan because we don't have space
to add any room
because it's just one room
and it's a mezzanine too right look at
it offering impressive views of the
skyline
what is that fence
wow
you know someone's gonna fall off of
that somebody's gonna follow their death
that fence looks like two friends over
not enough room one friend's gonna push
you gonna fall out of your apartment die
great it even includes a dishwasher and
a water whoa
what did you watch sure wow
if you're a millionaire you can get a
dishwasher too
holy moly
oh look at that modern dishwasher cat or
washing
that's nice got the painters tape and
everything around here
yeah
that's so you know it's fresh
which might not sound crazy look at that
sweet leather couch let's see it's not
included you gotta it's not furnished
this is damn dammit
what i have to pay furniture rare for
apartments like this that were built in
the 1920s still beware
the 1920s
rattling down the hallways of the dead
people from the great depression
a hundred year old building that sure
there has no underlying issues in those
please spend a billion dollars an
elevator so you'll be getting a daily
workout it's actually not as small as
most wait that's the peasant quarters we
have those in uk everywhere
we're like wait why is there another
staircase here and like oh that's world
um
yeah and no one uses it everyone just
used it as for storage wow yeah oh i
remember that because i wouldn't visit
it i was like all this stuff like out
here by these stairs yeah this is
someone gonna fall down he's like no no
nobody ever uses them oh man like how do
they get to their apartments they use
the other stairs the and these
[ __ ] put passive aggressive
notes on all on my christmas tree saying
it's blocking the stairway literally
just walk around it and they said they
were gonna charge me they put a note
saying that we're gonna charge you to
dispose of this you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how dare you i'm so pissed off cam i've
never been this angry
how dare you
properties
staircases
christmas tree
well i don't have space because modern
day dystopia has no storage where am i
supposed to put it
in the peasant staircase
oh i'm not allowed because you can't
maneuver your way around it
so sorry about that
the peasants are angry like yeah maybe
they the ghosts put them up it's just
unbelievable the peasant ghost
how am i supposed to serve my leash we
have we have this area that no one uses
but i'm not allowed to store anything in
it except everyone else does it as well
unbelievable actually not as small as
most people would expect but as we hop
but it's a fire hazard thing
who aren't you today
[Laughter]
sorry i need to get over it my bad
oh that's good then we really start to
feel the squeeze the city of lights is
renowned for its food its architecture
and its bubbling culture so people have
this romantic view of paris based on
movies and and media but then they come
and visit it and they found that their
idea of paris isn't what they thought
right i actually have a relative that i
was talking to just a few nights ago
that was talking about they went to
paris and it's like oh it's been so
romantic we did all the things we like
did the lock on the bridge and all this
stuff and it was just kind of and we'll
never go back
so it's all coming full circle now i
like it yeah and it's oh it's based on
the japanese pari
uh thank you yeah because so many
japanese people come and it's such a
culture shock for them there's like
let's play there's dog poop everywhere
in the rain
it's kind of sad i don't know it's it is
a pretty city i'm not everyone
completely paris but considering the
average amount of percentage i have some
issues over 300 bucks with a million
dollars on hand in the french capital
you'll be able to sign the deed to well
a studio apartment
nice you'll be spending your time
walking down the sand visiting museums
and watching the world go by from a
street side cafe this tiny 666
[Laughter]
wallpaper
what is that the kitchen and
lemon what is it this is your this is
your whole room it's 600 square feet you
pretty much get a room
oh what it okay what is wrong with the
piece of wood on the wall up there do
you see it's painted white above the
window it's supposed to be some kind of
support but it looks like it's about to
fall apart oh that yeah that's something
they painted the beams those are the
beams yeah they're wooden beams
they look pretty
somebody's been chewing on this dude
those are some old ass beans dude yeah
damn
why would they paint them white they
look better exposed i don't have maybe
not those those look pretty rough
maybe that's why they painted them yeah
yeah now but that that's common
if you go on in the market um in uk and
i'll show you later they all have these
exposed beams because it's a sense of
luxury now for some reason but it's
really not
and in my crappy stuff is luxury
vehicles yeah weird
rustic barn door
or whatever it is it's like a smart
piece of
crap it's like great yeah and they paid
a hundred thousand dollars for it what a
tasteless mess this is like from the
lamp to the couch to this
i don't know
yeah exactly oh you want to sit on the
couch
there you go department sits in the
seventh houseman within walking distance
of the eiffel tower like such so
gorgeous on the outside but then this is
what you get hello you're welcome cool
thanks thank you i get some blimp
wallpaper oh you were right it is one
room
one one room it's like a very top look
at this angle too
hey penthouse it's the penthouse can
look at these yeah the other
yeah you can't you can't stand up
straight in this
unplanned living space makes it feel a
little bigger for a squiz over a million
bucks what you're really paying for here
is the location from a chic city full of
history and charm to a rapidly evolving
desert oasis let's jet on over to dubai
i think on the underlying anger it's
just against boomers because they are
the ones who did this
they are the ones that [ __ ] us with
the house
uh dubai is actually reasonably priced i
think you can
in a region synonymous with luxury with
a million dollar check you could find
yourself living in the world's tallest
building the burj khalifa where a
two-bedroom i've seen this
apartment covering some 1800 square feet
is ready to be swept up check out those
views at a comparably cheap 353 dollars
per square foot the dollars stretch a
lot further in the uae
there you go
the problem is ken
it's all blood money right
having you heard all the stories that
they they they get immigrants to come
and build and they take their passports
and they force them to to to work under
these insane conditions and like i mean
live in australia now but i'm from
america so i have no idea what you're
talking oh okay all right
i'm just saying you know dubai this is
not something not so pretty underneath
the facade i guess you could say
how do you feel about like living in
cities
i hate it no london
london is
the worst place on the planet yeah i
want i can't wait for london to show up
because it's the worst yeah it's like
yeah i get if you like have a a job like
in the city and like a yeah it's if you
don't have a choice yeah then you go
live in the city and you oh you want to
pay that extra money for that view sure
go for it but our yeah if you're like us
if you work on the internet you go live
wherever you well not wherever you want
you can't go japan
thank you
but now it's like they realized with the
pandemic right that wait you can
actually work from home that actually
works oh so we don't need this office
spaces in the cramped up cities and oh
wait so that's not actually not a
necessity oh cool it's almost like we
just set all this up that is horrible
and
for no reason
so for real estate prices to go up
because everyone is in high demand right
we got the new baby i got three kids now
right i don't even want to like raise my
kids in like a city because i'm like
what's the point like why no
awful city story is fun when you're
you're a kid though i used to like get
to go visit like it's gonna go oh let me
go visit this place you know let me go
visit new york and see it but i don't
wanna live in it well that's gonna be
the the case in the future look at all
the big cities all tourism cities are
just going to be like airbnbs
right yeah no one's going to actually
live in the cities because it's too
expensive properties right yeah yeah
yeah it's already happening
the person that bought that 10 years ago
was raking in the money
anyway willing to live a little further
inland than that same bag of cash could
buy you an enormous
3566 square foot family home which
boasts a pool in a beautiful front
garden well it seems pretty obvious what
you would pick right
you want to live in a giant tower
nothing's toronto the home of the most
expensive property in all of north
america toronto hey i didn't realize how
expensive canada was me either it's
incredible insane about to learn all
right here you go toronto is crazy
expensive footage average of 804 this
ontarian city edges out los angeles and
rome in its terms of price right if
you're hoping of living amidst the
hustle and bustle of the downtown area
look out because your cash will be swept
away in no time believe it or not this
tiny home let's be honest
no
isn't it sad
it is it's so sad at least we left the
water bottle out for you know
nice
he gets something
the fence is broke though i just love
the idea like you're a millionaire
congratulations what are you gonna do
this is the place in sydney is telling
me about this is the same place
looks a little more more than a shack or
tools was listed for a million bucks the
blueprint shows it's like besides all
odds of the system you made it you
you're right you did it you did it
it's insane you're the one percent of
people
two bedrooms in one bathroom with the
property notably located smack bang in
the middle of little italy of course if
you were gonna buy this place the value
comes from the land on which it sits not
necessarily the house itself right you
don't say down under awesome oh here we
go let's go let's go
long been obsessed with property and the
continually rising prices
prove it the vibrant city of melbourne
is famous for its arts culture and
coffee but it's also that's what you're
paying for ken
the cops
unfortunately famous for its wallet
draining real estate oh look at that
lovely art ken aren't you glad aren't
you glad
i can't wait to be there man
just shy of a million americans you
could sweep up this spacious
three-bedroom two-bathroom house in the
affluent summer that looks on that field
front and back yard sits conveniently a
one-minute stroll from the tram stop and
just a quick 10-minute drive to the
sandy shores of st kilda beach keep in
mind however that in melbourne and in
fact most populated cities costs can
vary substantially the median melbourne
house price of 881 000 could get you a
tiny flat next to the oceans at least
this is like the only one that had like
nice interior decorating yeah yeah i
like what he's saying right here i don't
know if you're picking up on this but
he's talking about the insanity of the
australian real estate market he's like
eight hundred thousand dollars can give
you this small apartment or i can get
you a whole goddamn house because nobody
knows the value of anything in australia
they're just like i don't know oh it's
so fluctuating you're like yo bruh you
want a one percent you know
interest loan sure
take it go buy whatever it's nuts dude
damn i've been looking at houses since i
got here this is insane huh it's so
crazy or a five-bedroom mansion on rural
outskirts yeah there you go as we spin
the globe once more 9600 miles northwest
of the victorian capital is our next
destination destin point near pensacola
florida oh okay so we're done we're in
australia shoot we're about to get this
mansion for a million dollars right here
so florida is cheap thing i think um
anywhere in america outside of like
major cities is cheap hmm why is that i
don't know
how can it how can he how like how can
it be that different well i understand
like the land but even then like the
price of construction seems to also
fluctuate so much
everything in this world that has a
price on it the value isn't what it's
the valuation the value is what people
will pay for it and people keep paying
these prices so that's the price wow
well there you go
it makes sense
yeah out in the middle of nowhere you
know someone's like hey i'm selling my
house for a million dollars and they're
like
no
i'll go
next door right by buy a different one
you know yeah but in the cities i guess
you've got more people that want to move
to la and live the la dream and go live
in culver city or whatever and be
miserable
average price per square foot around
here is 215 almost five times cheaper
than new york
cash in hand you'll be able to snap up a
truly stunning beachfront retreat
picture this
1850 square feet of see this is what i
expect for a million dollars ken right
this is what i've been told living space
three bedrooms and three bathrooms all
renovated and unbeatable views of yeah
even get great views it's not like you
live in the desert
right you'll get your
as part of a gated community you'll also
have access to two swimming pools a hot
tub two swimming pools what's the
drawback it's a little further out from
major cities
is that a drawback
i moved to florida i have to commute oh
no
why would i want to go to a city oh god
i moved to florida ken from
japan ah did can i move back
i'll go to florida florida is where you
go to retire in america that's where all
the old people go yeah well they figured
it out didn't they god damn yeah folks
hold on to your wallets because our next
city is about as expensive as they come
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the most
exorbitant what would that be not only
in europe but monaco nestled on the
french riviera sporting a reputation for
high rolling luxury this of course is
monte carlo
is that in monica monte carlo where the
rich kids go to flicks yeah
is that just yeah uh principality of
monaco oh okay
because they don't have any taxes right
under scale mileage yeah i think it's an
expensive prime residential market and
none of its regions comes with prices as
sky-high as the infamous monte carlo at
4 924 dollars per share
what can we expect for a million bucks
not much yeah i remember i
looked into this for no reason of course
yeah no no
doesn't do taxes yeah yeah i got you
you'll get a tiny tiny 377 square foot
studio with barely half a kitchen but
then again switzerland you know i don't
have taxes either and it's not like
that's crazy expensive but i guess it's
such a small area
something about living near water just
drives people crazy huh
as someone has lived by the ocean for 10
years now or in eight years don't do it
don't do it it's it ain't worth it it's
dumb you get all this weather too i
could take a 50 minute walk down the
road and go to like to the beach you
know and that's cool that i can do that
but i've done that
a handful of times right the months that
i've been here so it ain't happening and
it ain't gonna get more let me tell you
that but you'll be spending all your
time on your yacht anyway right for that
kind of money we could live like royalty
in a place like arizona the cactus
filled state arizona
back to america yeah let's go to arizona
and be kings king speaking of taxes all
my tax people are like don't touch
america they're crazy they will they
will suck you up
they are pretty very greedy it is
quickly gaining steam as a retiree's
dream destination why because with a
million bucks you can live in a truly
astonishing mountain estate just like
this one situated outside so you are
literally in the desert on this one okay
interesting
well there's a lesson to be learned
you know speaking of florida and here
the retirees you just got to figure out
where all the old people are moving and
that's probably the best spot to live
because they they're just enjoying the
rest of their life right yeah and the
market is always moving because um you
know booters yeah
60 square foot mansion boasts sweeping
views of the rugged desert landscape
with barely a neighbor in sight it
features floor to ceiling windows a
decked out games room and an expansive
patio better yet it also comes with a
237 square foot guest house basically
i'm not sold on arizona i ain't moving
to arizona i don't care how cheap it is
sorry arizonians
ain't nobody got no internet out here
the same size as the one we just saw in
monte carlo the median list price per
square foot in tucson is 125
one of the most affordable we've seen so
far yeah but you're in the desert though
what do you do what do you do there what
do you do here
right
what happened
you go on walks you're going walks yeah
twist your ankle and perish because
there's a hospital you know 300 miles
away from you maybe get bitten by a
snake in the crowded city of hong kong
real estate prices continue to soar for
just under our budget we can grab this
cozy 708 square foot hong kong is
discovery bay area the floor plan
features three small bedrooms but hey
three is better than one right plus two
bathrooms and a wonderful oceanfront
view on average square footage in hong
kong is three thousand twenty four
dollars yikes that puts this asian
administrative region on the map as one
of the priciest places to live but with
such booming cultural business and
entertainment scenes you won't be
spending much time at home anyway let's
look for something a little roomier
shall we straddling the border between
asia and europe is none other than any
guesses yep istanbul what no i would not
have guessed that
kind of like estonia or something yeah i
kind of want japan to show up but i
don't think it will cultural melting pot
this enormous city actually isn't too
expensive property wise picture yourself
living here in this captivating
five-bedroom villa which overlooks the
sea it sits in the highlands yeah that
looks pretty damn maybe a water man
is simple is that cheap sought after
area
includes a private pool and direct
access to a beach and rests over eight
thousand six hundred square feet of land
while the interior is spacious and full
of amenities the selling point is
clearly that amazing backyard this house
has a backyard
what do you mean
what are you on about
you bought this big house just so you
could have a backyard
nice clearly that amazing backyard this
house technically cost that looks
awesome five million but if we put our
negotiation skills to the test hopefully
we can squeeze it into our budget
overall istanbul is as cheap as chips i
feel like if i go to istanbul i'll be
kidnapped or something then dude i hate
it whenever like a real estate agent is
like oh look at this look at this
spacious backyard i'm like please i'm
not buying this house for the backyard i
mean that's a plus
come on you don't like a backyard you're
not a backyard man i do like it but they
like they try to like sell you on like
the features of the backyard like oh
look it's got a guy's got a garden here
it's got a swing and i'm like this stuff
costs like nothing in comparison to the
house i hate realtors they're they're
worse than car salesmen i hope they all
nothing but you know what i mean oh they
all stopped taking six percent off my
my house sales
minimum i they always try and sell you
on stuff that doesn't exist like oh look
at this backyard can you imagine what
you can do with here
you could put a jacuzzi there you could
put a pool here like yeah [ __ ] i
know that i don't need you to tell me
that you idiot i hate it when they give
you the rushed feeling of like oh you
better put an offer in or it's gonna be
gone
i know if i want it i will leave me
alone i'm gonna die i can make my own
decisions thank you very much yeah
geez
adult problems bro or are they trying to
take over everything so you're looking
for a house
we should sit down and have a meeting
i'll find you i'll start recommending
your houses and you just hate all of it
yeah exactly but i'm the one that's
going to sell you this
i can google okay i don't need you
well if i find you a house and it's one
that i also represent the seller then uh
then
yeah yeah they're leeches whatever it's
called bro i don't need you god damn it
115 per square foot as we jet set over
to indonesia they don't call bali the
island of paradise for no reason on this
volley has to be cheap right dollar goes
a long way simplistic luxury easy to
come by estates typically sell for
around 269 dollars per square foot take
this modern place for example with seven
figures at our disposal we could set up
shop in this open and bright
three-bedroom villa a lot of balinese
properties have small private pools and
this spot is no damn all right maybe
bali i mean i've been there it was
gorgeous you can serve it's got amazing
do not serve no i don't but i this is
their dream i want to surf okay that's
my million dollar dream you got to do it
surf we can learn how to surf together
because hell yeah it's going to be an
old man out there transferring
unlike most new home purchases around
the world this one even comes fully
furnished allowing you to save a few
bucks on furniture and spend a little
more at one of the hundreds of delicious
restaurants in the area indonesia and
southeast asia in general
damn bali bali is late i will say that
yeah it looks pretty
that's probably places like that are
probably where i'll be taking vacation
because that's the only thing close to
australia and go to that new zealand
yeah i recommend it all right ken all
right welcome to england you become a
millionaire here's here's what you get
incredible
oh wow look at that awesome spacious oh
wow look at that lovely floor and the
wall and the ceiling and my god wow they
got stuffed in that drawer this is
incredible a million dollars you're
living like a cane that used to be a
fireplace right there yeah
what is that yeah there used to be a
fireplace but they cost too much to fix
it so now it's a rock
so why all right
you love this this is as nice as it it's
gonna ever gonna look right because this
is the photos used to sell it but back
there in the background are those cords
about the door back there on the ground
yeah yeah that's cords they're hiding
behind that elevator elevator radiator
uh
oh
wow oh look at that kitchen oh it comes
with a dishwasher can a million
look what you're getting oh look at this
you get a bath
whoa
in a window you can open it i guess oh
wow in the backyard i mean you could put
a pool here okay
i'm just sitting on someone's property
here i just realized but the point the
point is like this is what you get for a
million like get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah or you can look at the outskirts of
the city and have to do like if you work
maybe like a little bit of a no no no no
no no
no no no this is the problem with the uk
you go outside here i'll be unbiased
i'll pick somewhere outside and see this
is what you get outside wow it's so
lovely inside look at this carpet here
on the wow
this is incredible look at that kitchen
it's so nice look at that cat and you
get the cat maybe too right there well
they got the trash can is right there
oh
yeah
yeah but they do that they don't build
them in all the ways so you have to have
an exposed trash can what are you going
to do
wow
oh wow
it's always you get a backyard i guess
it's zelda oh wow look at the hot tub
vince
there's just stuff everywhere man wait
wait it's a carpeted bathroom
oh no
it's a
carpeted would you do that
this ring smells great
why does it smell like mildew in here
well we gotta stop this video all right
thanks for watching
i i can do a [ __ ] 24-hour video on
this [ __ ] it pisses me off man but there
you go
check out ken and um subscribe to me for
more rich people problems that i will
complain about
bye